the Royal Bank of Canada has what
they're calling a secret weapon and it
comes to staying on top of the FinTech
world and his name is Eddie Ortiz he is
a serial inventor whose name is on a
handful of us patents tied to rbcs
payment systems like the cloud-based
digital wallet joining us as a reporter
who tracked this story down Bloomberg's
doug alexander good to have you with so
tell us a bit about Eddie Ortiz and how
he's how long he's been with RBC and I
guess his value yeah he's actually been
with the Royal Bank for quite a long
time but really he's from past six years
he's been the guy that's been behind or
leading the team that's been developing
all the interesting consumer apps and
things in that the digital FinTech type
of things for the bank interesting and
so I guess what makes him RBC's secret
weapon in your story you you point to
that because he's he's he's clearly
coveted by the leadership of the bank he
is he is I mean it so much so that back
in a couple years ago he actually had
wanted to move down to Florida for
family reasons and Royal Bank which does
not have a presence in Florida actually
opened up a an office for him there and
actually worked out in their favor
because when they moved him down there
he ended up in the state where there's a
lot of talent and the areas of
cybersecurity fintech and such like that
so he NASA to right close to NASA I've
got Walt Disney down there you've got a
great university that's got a tech focus
or can computer science focus so he's
been able to recruit a lot of talent and
really build his team from that so what
kind of things is he working on right
now I mean there's a big question around
Canadian banks and what they'll do next
in fintech and we're behind or ahead or
so on what's he working yeah and it's
funny because all the banks have their
own sort of innovation hubs or digital
hubs whatever you want to call it and of
course I'm not going to tell us what you
know specifically they were working on
but he did give me a little hint on a
few things I mean his team was the one
that actually was involved in
integrating the Apple pay and other
digital wallet but some of the things to
look forward to going forward they're
working with artificial intelligence so
that you couldn't basically talk to and
app and or text and will respond to
whatever your banking needs are sort of
like Siri yeah a financial Siri is what
he called it the other one is watching
that's a big push for all the banks and
world bank's working on something there
including a loyalty program that's block
chain backed